appreciate it  not me i'll stay for a woman for sure  you get the last question  wouldn't it stay for you guys  fair enough  what what is your level of confidence  right now that you guys will be able to  figure out the things that you're  talking about because we still have  games to play  you gotta  you know until you stump me out  cut my head off  bury me 12 feet under then i got a  chance  [Music]  so that's my confidence  you know obviously you know at the end  of the day we got to come in and win  ball games and we got to play better but  as long as  we got more games to play um  we still have a chance  so that's my confidence  you know i hate losing i feel like  poop right now  um  but tomorrow's a new day and i'm gonna  be prepared and ready for the clippers  on thursday but  that's just that's my mindset that's  just why